Được đó, tại quyết định số chính xó ba ngày 22 tháng 10 năm 2020,
bộ công thương đã điều trình không dờ cao điểm từ mô hình chia làm hai đợt vào buổi chưa
và buổi tôi, sang tập trung hoàn toàn vào buổi tôi từ mỗi bài giữa bác nguyên
hành hai dở bác nguyên các ngày trong tuần trường chủ nhật.
Công dờ thấp điểm được sắc định từ không dờ đến xó dở sáng.
Tuy nhiên, không dờ mới hiện chưa chính thức áp dụng, giống bộ công thương đang hoàn thiện
dừa rồi thông tư số xó mguyên, quy định thực hiện giá bắn điện.
Theo sự thảo sự rồi, không dờ mới sẽ đặc áp dụng lối với khách hàng sản xuất,
kinh dùa anh sự dụng điện theo cơ chế dở cao điểm thấp điểm.
Lãnh đạo y về nger biệt, giá điện xinh hoàn hiện bắn được tính theo biểu giá bắn lại
điện bật thang và không phân biệt theo thời gian sự dụng trong hai.
Bởi vì việc thấy rồi không dờ cao điểm không làm thấy rồi chỉ vì tình điện của cao khổ ra đình.
Theo y về nguyện điều trình không dờ nhằm phản nánh xát hơn thực tế và nạn hệ thống điện,
khi nguyên cười như câu sự dụng điện tăng cao vào buổi tối, chính sách này hướng tới quyến phích khách hàng
điều trình như câu sự dụng điện hợp lý, vóc phần dạm áp lực cho hệ thống điện cuúc ra và nân cao việu quả vận hành.
Đối với các chuyên nghiệp sản xuất kinh dùa anh, i về anh quyến nghệ chủ đậu ra soát kế hoa sự dụng điện,
nể thích ơn với cùng dơ mới khi được chính thức áp dụng.